it's like you'll called each other to
match like today that's it the Scots
Among Us yes the the Scott is rubbing
off on you like at home yes you are
amazingly beautiful pregnant that does
not happen for all of us that is amazing
how which baby is this baby number three
and done I told the doctor I was like
take everything out that you need to
take out so I said that on my second one
and then she said did she tell you um
well it just depends on how much like
whatever I don't going get graphic but
it depends on like things or whatever I
was like girl if I get out of here and I
have tubes in this body we're going to
have a problem I was like yeah cuz I
feel like some of us you could just like
and you get pregnant that's that's yeah
well I didn't honestly think we could my
fiance and I were talking about it I'm
like listen I've had multiple
miscarriages and I'm about to be 40 so
I'm you know I I didn't know in our the
first month trying oh my God it's
powerful it can be powerful do you have
like Scottish Power when are you yeah
there you go he's like yeah
yes so so are you feeling good are you
your due dates is it soon four weeks oh
my gosh what are you doing here gosh and
exactly do you know how to deliver a
baby I was like I was having
contractions back there I was like just
braat and Hicks we're fine oh my gosh
are you feeling okay no girl I'm ready
like we're like I was like K baby runs
up like it's time get out yeah a and
then you get the skin on skin friend
just had a baby and I'm like I keep
texting about skin on skin time I love
that time it's it's that's that's the
piece where I just I just want to see
what he looks like and just holds on
it's a it's a beautiful thing that we've
created something that I didn't think
this would be our my story What a
Beautiful Surprise as well yeah so okay
so your fiance is Scottish so yes when I
go to Scotland no offense sometimes I
have no idea what the hell they're
saying so and and they have no idea what
I'm saying by the way cuz hello accent
um but do you have did you have a
problem ever like in the beginning in
the very he has is a very thick Scottish
accent so at first I'm like and now I
see my friends leaning in and they go
what did he say and I'm like well he
said was if you you know the bin is the
trash and then the garden is the
backyard and then you know so just but
he's he slows down for my friends yeah
which helps but now he's back to speed
but I cannot understand his family um so
is there like a confusing Scottish
phrase I had a guy he was one of the
drivers when I went over there touring I
was like can you just teach me some of
the you know like a thing that y'all say
or whatever and then I couldn't learn it
cuz it was so damn difficult
so can you teach me like a Scottish
phrase which like a i on the I mean it's
just it's probably because I speak too
fast all right pal how you doing just
what Okay you Okay you Okay like yeah me
if I'm okay what did you just say right
now though all right pal oh all right
you doing it's just like like one word
it's the hardest accent to even try to
replicate because whenever I try to
sound like my fiance I either go Russian
or like he's like I'm not Russian I was
like I know but that's like how it comes
out so I can't do accents either I'm
terrible for some reason I always end up
Jamaican I don't know why it's so sad
I'm not mer Street you know she could
just like float through yeah anyway well
so you're getting married in Scotland
right yes which is beautiful we're very
excited we just secured the venue
yesterday actually so yeah next summer
that's a that's amazing is your family
going to make the trip obviously his
family is there proba it's going to be
very small but yes like about 40 of us
that are that's kind of the greatest
thing about a destination wedding is
that everybody doesn't come like you
know what I'm saying you're just like
you're like oh it's because it ends up
being sometimes about everybody else
rather than the bride and groom exactly
and we just wanted our closest people
together to celebrate you know this
beautiful thing that again we never
thought was gonna yeah about so all
right well are there any for one more
are there yes room for he's hanging out
and SC wait are there any cool things in
Scotland do you do do they have like
wedding things like any kind of cool
wedding so we're going to do a mini
Highlands game for Min games what which
should be fun I don't really know what
that entails but he keeps saying Min
Highland I'm like yeah like archery like
things or like oh no archery have we
throw cers we toss Tree Trunks and lob
rocks around and you thought archery was
weird and then you throwing tree trunks
you want to come let's do it throw you
having an a kie yes we're going to do
Kay we're like the whole like I want
like the tree they're going to work kils
it's a Madness it's organized Madness
it's a they it's dancing but everyone
dances and they very organized but it's
literally gets faster and faster and
it's chaos it's chaos organized chaos
it's brilant this sounds fun can't way
yeah that sounds way better than
weddings over here yeah yeah I mean and
I you know the baby's going to wear Kilt
my son Jace he's going to wear so it's
going to be real cute oh my gosh I love
it all right so I mean I feel like we've
had kind of similar worlds I feel like
we've had like similar things kind of
happen with us um in recent years and so
to write a book first of all is so brave
I mean I mean I wrote songs to get my
stuff out but like post divorce like
writing a book that like that's hard to
be that vulnerable after something like
so tragic in your own life like how was
that it was really hard and you know my
ex and I we wrote a book after The
infidelity in our marriage and um and
how we got through that and we actually
had another book deal about trust and
that's when I found out about more
things I think you know once I kind of
rose up from all that it was I needed to
write this book about trusting myself
and moving on and this book is it's
truly about my journey and looking in
the mirror cuz I realized I'm like okay
when I started the book I was very angry
I was bitter I was angry I was mad and
then I realized that I had to kind of
look in the mirror and go okay there's a
lot of pieces that I contributed I had a
lot of Brokenness even before I met him
so I got to fix these whatever this
Brokenness is to not repeat the same
toxic patterns that I was bringing to it
as well which is so helpful for anyone
going through because I don't think
people realize too you go through like a
divorce it's loss it's like grief yeah
it's a different I had never experienced
anything quite like that well your world
is taken away from you the world that
you imagine for your children and that's
not a world that I wanted for my kids so
I had to go okay how how do I now single
parent how do I walk through this how do
I walk through despising this man that
ruined my life but then realizing now it
was the greatest thing that ever
happened to me knowing that like I
finally fell in love with myself for the
process I love cuz that is the hardest
part because I think the thing that I
went through and I I I find that you did
as well like um via talking about trust
and what this book is about is literally
it's the you're not TR like the the fact
that when you wake up one day and you go
I cannot trust my decisionmaking skills
like there is something wrong with me
like I I'm like because I made a
decision to do this and I made a
decision to do that and it's like then
that's the messed up part is in therapy
is when you learn you're like I'm having
a hard time just trusting me like let
alone someone else and I think there
there was that piece and then also like
I did not respect myself I didn't love
myself and so how why would I expect
that from someone else he didn't he
could never have given or how do you
know how to receive it if you don't know
how to give it to yourself
1% writing the book also must have been
like a process of therapy as well right
it was yeah and and just doing the you
know the hard work and really digging
deep and go okay what are what are all
the messages that I've believed for the
last 30 plus years of my life that I
have to now retrain my brain that oh
wait a minute I don't deserve that and I
do deserve respect and in this new Rel
ship everyone's like well why is it
different I'm like he respects me but
it's because I now know I deserve
respect yeah oh my gosh yes now you know
I'm so thankful for the relationship
that I do have with my ex now we have a
great co-parenting situation and we
really formed a new relationship we had
to let go of the resentment because we
both had resentment from the marriage
and so it was this it was able to go
okay now this is our new relationship
and moving forward and uh and that's not
easy to do no it's not but we love our
kids that's what I'm saying it's the
kids that really changes that I I feel
um because you'll do anything for them
have you ever had a moment like that
when you figured out you went through
something rough and then you figured out
something about yourself that you didn't
know I don't know I think time does that
and age as well right and I I guess even
now I'm kind of going through that you
know I I'm I'm in the the 40 club and uh
yeah you just you get a lot time to like
reflect and I'm also coming to the end
of a a journey of my acting in a certain
show that I'm doing so yeah I guess
you're I'm always reflecting on that but
I guess acting is almost my therapy you
know writing books is also another way
of doing but well it's an and it's you
know we've all been told messages from
our childhood trauma or past and or from
past relationships and you know not
letting that be the truth and so knowing
what is the truth and trusting that and
it's it's hard sometimes old messages
still come up like oh maybe I'm not good
enough it's like no those are old
messages what are the new what's the new
and what's what's true yeah oh it's
going to be the most helpful book ever
for so many people including me yall be
reading it um so you're your 40th right
it's coming up so do you have big
birthday plans so this is I mean other
than the one
present anything going on anything God
surely played a joke on me because my
30th birthday I was like I'm alone I'm
single I've got no one like you know so
my 40th I'm like I'm going to blow it
out we're going to have this big party
and on an island and fireworks when I
got my due date for the birthday it for
the birth it was like my 40th birthday I
was like you've got to be kidding me oh
my God but now it's um we have I'm
delivering two weeks prior and we're
going to do not because because of that
but um you were like you were like
excuse me but I need my moment some
complications so we're delivering a
little earlier but the um we're going to
do a murder mystery party and so excited
always wanted to do that so I was like I
almost got to do in one time come on
yeah to Nashville that seems so fun have
you ever done that no but I'm guessing
you you get like someone knows who's the
murderer and so we have some actors
coming to the house and then some of us
are suspects and then one's the murderer
and then we try and figure it out it's
going to be themed I'm into oh I want to
be the murderer yeah now we're gonna
we're goingon to unpack that later like
of why all right let's do another
commercial break everybody Jana's new
book is called the next chapter you can
find it wherever books are
[Music]
[Applause]
sold thank you guys have a great night
I'm going
home